um let's go coca-cola i'll be going
yeah yeah right roll out so true jolly
podcast just me and lauren's talking
here because we've both watched
neverland
uh leaving neverland documentary uh with
the michael jackson story of touching
kids basically
doing awful things um and we both
thought
it would probably be good to do a
podcast we would really get into it
and talk about what we felt after
watching it we grew up as michael
jackson fans so
there's probably going to be michael
jackson defenders in the comments
viewers wanting to sit there and be like
oh you just hear michael jackson
like i was i think obsessed is almost a
word
really with michael jackson it's silly
looking at me now because i look like
i don't look like a michael jackson fan
if i remember the first time i watched
the moonwalker movie
i was trying to do the [__] moonwalk
uh billy
uh i mean i made an effort but i
remember at one point
i was on holiday and there was a michael
jackson impersonator there
and he was dancing and i literally got
up on stage and danced with him because
i thought i could do all the moves so
when when i was watching the documentary
and seeing them on stage on the talent
shows i was like
like that was me really like i remember
being like that as well
what the footage they use in the
documentary is very relatable childhood
footage yeah a lot of very nostalgic
yeah so many people would have
remembered doing the same yeah
because michael jackson's music was
amazing
like that for that era as well he was
miles ahead
of the competition people try and equate
of this era
oh well what would michael jackson have
been you can't like you can't say
drake was like michael jackson or kanye
michael jackson
was on a planet all on his own musically
no one
at the era he was in come close to him
there was michael jackson
and everyone else and you could maybe
see madonna someone like that was sort
of floating off to the side
and part of that is also that he was the
chosen one in the music industry to be
that person he
embodied uh publicly everything that
people thought was good and righteous
and
you know he come from a good family
background
all over him and all his brothers and
pretty soon
you see if you're following the story
that there's some there's some weird
[__] going on in the family
michael goes away he comes back his
looks changed his
skin color is changing it became
apparent that he was a bit weird
from day from early on it came yeah it
became apparent that he had ident an
identity that he wasn't necessarily
happy with and that he was struggling
with it and he'll do that yeah for me
but yeah the music was amazing
and it was a phenomenon that people
hadn't really seen
since maybe the level of presley or the
beatles oh yeah rolling stones
it was that level for me there was elvis
presley king of rock and roll
michael jackson king of pop like they
are arguably the two biggest musical
stars
of all time it was also in a time when
technology was
ramping everything up so quickly like
color tv
was really in the the point of its prime
at that point mtv
started mtv was beginning there was also
like there was people beginning to
like experiment with visual effects like
you know they could make a whole city
now and
do those sort of things that was what
was interesting in tv mass media was now
global
it wasn't limited to america limited to
europe
it was something that blew him up and he
was the poster boy of that
in the documentary at this point is
where
michael starts getting introduced to all
his young fans and all his young kids
and
depending on what you believe at the
start he's
got a a relationship with kids that
other celebrities didn't have
and it seems quite sweet and innocent on
the servers back in the day
i'm sure it did because most celebrities
they're just living their [__] lives
they've got
a significant other they're not seeing
around with kids as much as this guy was
and what he said is he's all about the
children all about making
and he had not had a childhood so
therefore
and i don't know if this is a fair way
to put it but that's the way they say
because he was worked so hard as the
child star of the jackson five the dad
was on him
you're the money maker of this family
and you've got to do this for the family
so therefore once he became old enough
to do what he wanted he wanted to do kid
stuff because he'd missed out on all of
that
that was also part of his brand it was
the brand that was created for him and
around him as well
michael you're a child star you know you
embody all these things
you're a good wholesome beautiful guy
all that kind of stuff that was built up
around him
he was put in ads with kids people put
him alongside because they wanted to
make him look
like an older guy that was a child who's
relatable family values
and i remember seeing him walking around
like holding hands with kids a lot and
he probably seemed a tad weird as a kid
but you didn't question it
like because being a kid yourself and as
i was and
it was like oh that could be i could be
friends with michael jackson
that was like cool the fact that he was
mates with kids was like
oh wow like he actually he doesn't treat
kids like they're irrelevant he's
actually wants to be friends with them
this was also in a time when
movies and those sort of things cartoons
were portraying adults as
innocent people yeah people like batman
superman all those kind of things big
phenomenons who were good
to children they were kind that you know
they they were all the things you want
them to be
and he was the human version of those
things he was leading what was a really
unrealistic life to the point where
he revolutionized music videos so like
thriller for example
he was always a character and especially
in thriller and also
that many people wanted to work with him
because not only do you get to with
michael jackson
as someone who represents that time
you'll get a big budget as a director to
work with him but you'll be able to go
we want to do thriller we don't do this
michael let's do that and he goes yeah
and it gets carried away with it and
suddenly you can do whatever you want
as a director and as a company so in
leaving neverland you see
those um fans who idolize them get
introduced to him
one of them is wade who eventually went
on to become
a choreographer for nsync britney spears
and work in the music industry
and the other guy had aspirations as
well that michael
wanted to do um i can't remember the
other guy's name but he wanted to help
him
with becoming a film director and i
think wade wanted to be filmed
as well i think michael also slightly
opened up the possibilities in their
world
these guys let's be clear these kids
were not child stars who just run across
him
these were regular kids who lived in
regular places who got the
opportunity to meet michael yeah and he
embraced them yeah
it felt like a moment of fate when it
was like oh we we get to meet michael
jackson
today yeah to them it felt like faith
yeah to him
he meets kids every day yeah and this is
very normal for him
right but to them it's meeting your idol
and and that's the bit that
i really empathize with from their point
of view because they
describe them meeting michael jackson
and you come into this with a few
preconceptions because before the
documentary we've seen
he'd been accused of um doing
inappropriate things with a young boy
he settled out a court i think was like
20 million for that 25
you're like if you're on one side of the
fence you're like well it was all about
the money for the family they took the
money
at the end of the day if he was really
guilty you wouldn't have settled out of
court
you would have wanted them in bars
behind bars which is not true that's you
but i'm saying
what that's one side and then the other
side is if michael didn't want to
go to court and clear his name he must
be guilty there's a
confusion there at that point it was one
child
i in my head can suspend belief and say
i shouldn't have been in that position
however potentially
maybe someone was trying to make some
money out of them chris rock said it
best when the second case happened
he was like we love michael so much we
let the first kid
slide another kid like he made this
whole
bit about i thought it was [__]
groundhog day when that happened
doesn't how can you have another kid
have this say this because at that point
it's highly
unlikely that you're innocent of any
everything so two of the men
who testified uh were macaulay culkin
and uh wade
this weird guy after the fact changed
the story
and now has come out in this documentary
and said things did happen
so you can also understand and i think
the documentary is good at
sequencing things it's also very good at
explaining
and showing the thought process but all
this also the coercion of it
the way that you would be coerced into
well michael's a good guy
like so this all he made it feel very
like a process of well this is all very
natural
this is all very normal we love each
other why would we not
especially as a seven-year-old boy as
weird was when he met michael jackson
as a seven-year-old you are so little
you haven't got the comprehension of
what an
adult is swaying you towards and why
they're doing it and
and when you idolize michael the way
wade did
and you see him practicing his moves for
hours and hours and hours and to the
point where wade ended up having a
career
teaching justin timberlake how to dance
that's how good he got
you know this is a real obsession he had
with this guy
but to be honest with you when i watched
the documentary and it showed how
uh wade ended up in the hands of michael
jackson at neverland and all of that
i just thought yeah that could have
happened to me if if i'd met michael
jackson at that age
and he'd been like do you want to come
to neverland i would have said yes
i would have i would have been there i
wouldn't have done that i would have
begged my uh parents
as he did leave me with michael you go
off and go on it the rest of the holiday
in america i want to stay here why would
you want to leave your hero's house
and not only that but as a parent you
don't want to upset your kid if your kid
is
sitting there going please leave me with
michael jackson and
you've got the relationship with michael
um you think you have you think you do
because yeah because the parents were
very stupid in this because they should
have known better but they
they thought that's michael jackson of
course it's fine it's yeah
this he's not going to do anything he
just loves kids the kids though they
should have known better though the
parents should have [__]
i can accept them going along to
neverland and all of that but the minute
you
leave your kid in custody of this guy
you're a stranger that is wrong yeah and
that is where you [__] up
you basically you've been swept up in
the whirlwind of it and they were part
of it
and you know what he that's the problem
with perverts and pedophiles they prey
on people's good nature
so the problem that 99 of of uh
child abusers have is in order to get
yourself in a position
you take advantage of the child you need
to befriend
the family or you need to get in a
position of trust now with michael
jackson
because he was the superstar he was in
that position
the minute he said hello to anyone
because they're like oh it's michael
he's in my living room every [__] day
because this kid watches him all the
time
it's fine he's not going to be in any
trouble and i can understand that logic
at that time but i don't agree with it i
don't accept it it's awesome
i also see you know when you mention
macaulay culkin i think macaulay culkin
obviously he hasn't wanted to speak
about it since but he starred in movies
which were
about children doing great things
children
being able to defy the odds children
having oh my god like a one-off
how did this happen that what are the
chances it was an age when everyone
wanted to be
that one person that got the incredible
thing that happened to them it was like
miracle on 34th street home alone this
kid defied the odds and beat those
all movies those three movies around the
time like that that was real
american life then you can be the one
person that makes it to the top you can
be donald trump you can be any of those
people
so when michael jackson comes on go you
are the child that i want
to be friends with my friend yeah you
feel like you're in a movie you feel
like you are
you know you feel like you're kidding
home alone or whatever it is when you
idolize someone as a as a seven-year-old
or a ten-year-old or whatever
at that age to say you're impressionable
as an understatement you will do
anything to make that person like you i
would have went along with it the way
these kids did in terms of ending up in
that situation in neverland now
the the bit weight really i think will
if you haven't seen the the dock
there will be spoilers yeah we're
obviously going to go into it is where
he describes the sex
act with michael like that really
was disturbing because it was maybe if
you're a michael jackson fan you might
it might
you might watch a porno with michael
jackson and still not believe what he
did
you know because there's some people who
i think um
louis theroux called willfully blind uh
i think louie actually really
nailed it yeah his interview you've
gotta just give up on those people but
if you're
a logical person who's on the fence you
don't know if you watch this documentary
and you hear with the
detail and the emotion in which this
weird
guy speaks on what happened to him as a
seven-year-old
uh i don't really want to repeat it but
it was disgusting
and really disturbing and think of how
quickly michael went in
for it uh was even more just shocking
i don't know if you felt the same when
you were watching it but it made me feel
quite vulnerable while i was watching it
because i
i like i had the same feeling as you
which was that totally could have been
me
yeah we trust
like if i'd met him at that age which i
did if he'd said come right
for dinner like uh yeah totally tell me
to do anything if he tells me you
burgled someone i've probably done it
you know
tell me do anything because i just want
to make them happy yeah jeremy so with
that logic if you if anyone is
struggling to understand how this kid
end up that situation all you've got to
do is imagine because we all had idols
as kids
imagine that person come to you when do
whatever
for me you would do it chances are it's
also is a child
she's seven you're not living in the
real world as a child either
you're living in a world fun protection
yeah neverland as well you're in
neverland at that point
and there is a point in documentary
where they say what the parents
themselves even said they felt
like they're woken up in heaven because
it was a really fantastical place
but what that feeds into then is the
fact that kids don't yet know
how to build a healthy relationship with
another individual they don't know what
the boundaries are of that
they don't know where it stops and they
also don't know all the possibilities
and every day their parents are showing
them more things and the adults around
them are showing them more things
which make their lives better i bought
you this new toy look what this toy does
i bought your computer
and so michael jackson is another adult
in their lives who's bringing more
things
he's he's literally walking them around
toy shops with a trolling one
it's just irresistible for a kid and and
and they are trained he is training them
in in this documentary i personally
believe the accounts i heard in that
documentary me too
uh they're so emotional so detailed um
you know we we looked at r kelly's
interview the other day we ripped that
apart we couldn't rip this apart this
is too too precise too too much
conviction in the words that they're
using
can we for a second then go down the
route of where you would rip the
documentary apart and it's going to have
to be small details because it's a very
well put together documentary but if
there was purely a devil's advocate
on the basis that everyone deserves um
fairness there was a lot of music used
to indicate
emotion i get that you want to portray a
message but you could
argue that's biased towards the stories
that are being told
if these stories are not true
yeah i think that there should have been
um
someone behind the camera posing more
difficult questions at times
after they'd given these accounts so
there are rumors of or there are michael
jackson fans saying
you know wade has been um trying to
get a job he hasn't got a job he's
struggling financially that's why he's
doing all of these things
now uh that might all well be true uh he
might be struggling with money whatever
but the
the thing that really convinced me
against that uh
and we're jumping around here but just
go with it is when he
told his family and how his family
reacted
yeah now to me if you're trying
to get money and going to the media and
saying this happened to me i want the
money for it i want i want compensation
your family will be in on it they'll
know all right this is all
a ruse or whatever we're gonna get some
cash up with this
i'm too good of a judge of character in
my opinion and people might disagree
with us to have that family fool me
with acting at some point of all the
interviews i've seen from his wife to
his mother to his brother to his sister
to him i would have spotted a flow i
really couldn't see a floor there was so
much
inner pain in that family yeah that they
knew that this had gone on and they had
[__] up and they all believed what
they were saying that unless
wade was keeping this internally in
himself
lying to everyone else but he only knew
the truth and he was just
a great actor i don't believe it and i
don't believe where it is
that good of an actor of course it's
constructed to tell a story of course
it's constructed to
portray a message because this message
needed to become as compelling and as
hard-hitting as possible
because in the past you're facing a
resistance in the past people have [__]
footed around it and that's partly what
got
bashir in trouble so martin beshear uh
bought out a document
was it the early 2000's and it was
looking back at it now
a very insightful documentary well it
was even then though even then
so basically that was the documentary i
for me when i watched it where i thought
probably but not i can't
guarantee it but probably and at the
very least an incredibly [__]
weird and i want to say mentally ill man
i think there was a mental illness say
on show and there there was weirdness
and there was
hints of what he was doing i don't want
to diagnose him with anything and we
i think we should go back to that in a
second um the point but people
hammered bashir though absolutely some
people hammered him for exploiting
uh a big star some people hammered him
because they said you're lying about him
and you're trying to portray a certain
message of him
people angry with him for so many
different messages because they were
angry with what they were seeing on the
screen which was
michael jackson uncomfortable michael
jackson being challenged and also
the reality that on the one hand they're
hot as a michael jackson fan is telling
them i love this man
but their brain is going there's an
arguable evidence here how [__] up
this guy
is and i don't want to believe that so
who do i blame blame the interview and
that's a level
i'm not sure what it is but the closest
thing that i know to it's something
called cognitive dissonance
we've had low level bits of that on the
podcast where we've brought out things
in guests that people don't like and
they point the finger at us
yeah i understand that and that's
something i think that's something
called cognitive dissonance someone will
probably correct me on that but as far
as i know what cognitive dissonance is
you hear something that you know is true
but because you believe the other way
you get angry with the person that's
basically telling you the most
information
shoot the messenger so and that's that's
what happened with bashir and he was
basically
blackballed and yeah his career went
down of that which was weird because it
was a very powerful
insightful well well put together
documentary the only side of it was it
was not damning
it was not michael we know that you've
done this there wasn't enough thought
and that's partly because he knew he
could not go and do that because he
would then be sued because there's no
evidence there's no
it's all conjecture that's been settled
out of court so the kick so what you're
seeing is
we've seen one trial settled out of
court another trial
which he got off with because everyone
who he previously had things with
he brought in to be his defendants and
then a bashir documentary which wasn't
damning enough and he's
he's the teflon kid he can't pin him
down so this what you're saying had to
be
all guns blazing yeah and it had to be
and you i
can't imagine how difficult that is to
make as a documentary to get funded to
get all these things
because there will be many people who do
not want you to achieve your goals oh
yeah
there's some there's a big sony deal
with michael jackson yeah they say it's
around 250 million
uh the jackson estate all these kind
there's a lot more jackson's music for
the next 50 years
provided they kept his reputation clean
was going to continue
breaking the money it's not in the best
interest of these guys for this to
happen it also goes the other way where
michael jackson is not only overtly
throughout the industry and pepsi
commercials in all these big
companies in you know advertising
everything even
drake had a record out with mj recently
he's also
littered throughout tiny little things
kanye west good life samples michael
jackson there's so many michael jackson
samples about jay-z albums
there's so many little money earners and
not only that but
social like uh currency i guess in
michael jackson
[__] in kanye west's video for my
beautiful dark twisted fantasy the irony
of that now having
a massive michael jackson float going
behind him
as he parades through the desert it's
[__] mj's head
lit how are you then supposed to
separate out michael jackson
from popular society the biggest player
in the nfl
does a michael jackson dance when he
celebrates there are players in the nba
who love it
you can't separate that out that is
something that will make people want to
deny it because so many people love him
not only small but big
and not only that obviously he had
general society loved him
but he's got this sort of cult-like
following i want to say um
he was raised in a family of jehovah's
witnesses
and his music is very i want to say
religious like
you've seen uh what about us and he's
like
whatever it looks like the [__]
wolves and he's almost evangelical he's
very
he's yeah he's jesus let's be honest
yeah um in a lot of things he's very
he's pictured in white when he did that
you are not alone yeah he is
very like they're in heaven and [__]
like that so to a lot of people he holds
like a religious
sort of place for them it's it's beyond
a musician
it's it shaped their personality because
they looked him and they went he is good
i can also be good yeah he had a damaged
childhood i can have a good life
some of his songs are so powerful to
people
man in the mirror was the one that i
really liked like um all about
you know improving who you are by being
honest with yourself and
ironically um so it means a lot to
people and you have to
i respect that but equally when i'm hit
with
information as much as i don't want to
believe it if i believe it to be true
i can't [__] myself and i feel like
a lot of people
want to do that and when you're watching
the accounts of what happened
[Music]
it just it [__] blows you away and
but i think what
like people are saying about these guys
they're doing it for ulterior motives
why would you defend him in the in the
trial
and then come out later and say he
actually did things to me
that's really shitty basic psychology
really
because these guys were shaped and i
think the documentary does a great job
of showing how
they were basically coerced they were
coerced and also
what really made sense to me was weird
saying you know
i know he did these things to me but i
still loved him
yeah and i still didn't want to see him
go to prison that's what i found very
strange was throughout the documentary
the
the mother the wade and all the people
who speak still go and michael took us
to a great place and did
this and they're telling the story you
could say there's fond memories there
and this is the thing though is people
who have done what michael jackson have
done
are supposed to be completely evil and i
don't think he was
and i know i might get a bit of flack
there but what i mean is when he's
saying
children are you know so important and
yeah
i'm sure in his head he believed that i
and when he does these songs about
changing the world make it a better
place
i think he believed that i just think
that in his mind what he was doing to
these kids
there was nothing wrong with it yeah i
think he thought this is actually all
right this
and and that is where he's extremely
sick and [__] up
but you have to understand it you have
to first understand it before you can
tackle it which is a problem because
most people go
pedophile bad must all be bad yeah and
and ultimately i do think he's a bad guy
make no mistake but what i'm saying is
he's a complex guy with wade
it isn't just a case of he defended him
once that means he's always innocent
there's a lot more to it so with him
defending the first time and saying
you know i loved him and i was up during
the night worrying about him being in
prison
yeah things like that you're like i
understand that you
you had a relationship where you thought
you were in a relationship where it was
two people in love
yeah really it was an abuser and an
abused person but
he didn't know that and he and and that
can take
decades to work that out and i don't
even think he's even there yet
that is even still evidence of abuse
when that and very deep-seated
yeah when that person cares about that
and it took him going to therapy
to even admit it to another person and
then
admitted to his family and you've seen
how it ripped the family apart because
the dad had already committed suicide
and and both the fathers were
conspicuous in their absence yeah
and it was [__] awful how can you
watch this
and not be moved and not be blown away
by it
if you really want to
preserve the message of what michael
jackson said the love
the all the things that you that people
and fans
allegedly believe in then the best way
to do that
and if you want to preserve the message
of things like man in the mirror the
best way to do that
would be to put that framework onto this
case
and say then let's honestly evaluate
what this man did find out whether it's
true
and that's the best way to preserve his
memory because if you do not want these
questions
the only you're going to have to go to
that dark place which is basically
did he do terrible things to children
unfortunately
there isn't really evidence because of
how long it go it was and the nature of
the acts that happened
however what we do know is five kids
shared a bed with them one kid for 30
nights in a row
and five kids have come forward and said
he's abused them
now lightning doesn't strike twice it
certainly doesn't strike five [__]
times
this is not something i can uh ignore
and when people talk about how long it
takes for you to admit something like
this
like i told you before i was in a
situation once where
uh i was in uh my house with a
babysitter
and the guy was like you know a family
friend you trusted person
and for my memory's a bit fuzzy but i
remember
like it quite clearly when it happened
you know because you're [__] young
i might have been about eight nine maybe
ten at the push
this guy is rubbing on himself like
he didn't have anything out he was just
rubbing on himself going do you want me
to
join me to take this out i'll show you
what it is and that and
i went like i didn't i didn't have the
confidence even at that age to
speak but i was like no i i'm not being
frightened remember being like
[__] oh what what the [__] is going
on here because i know he is not going
to look like me
without his pants on i know like he's
like how old were you that time
i would say it would push like nine yeah
maybe eight so like when i was watching
this i was like oh and see
i can see how because this kind of um so
luckily for me anyway that never
happened and i remember
saying i didn't go into detail at the
time i was saying i don't want him
anymore yeah yeah
to me mom yeah and um i just remember
thinking how lucky i was to get out of
that situation
i am comfortable talking about this even
though it's a bit weird
it's a bit embarrassing for some reason
even for me to tell that now
is a bit embarrassing because it's like
when you're a man
and another man does that to you but you
were a boy at the time
you feel like a man now yeah you feel
like
your masculinity is being removed from
you
nothing happened to me no thank [__] but
i can only imagine if that's how i feel
recount in that memory imagine how
long it would take me if i'd had half
the bad experiences that these guys had
and you people wonder why it takes them
to be 30 [__] years old
or at least 40 sometimes to talk about
this sort of [__]
because the victims don't feel like
victims they feel like and this is what
michael was so good at doing they're
saying
if i go prison you go to prison if my
life's over your life's over
and you feel like you're in this joint
thing where
you know you're not you're not this
isn't it's not your
fault and that's one of the hardest
things for a victim to get their head
around
and i think uh is it sort of bad saying
if if anyone
uh does want to talk about it then there
are what place you going can go and talk
to people well
i think what was eminently um
evident in this as well was they didn't
know who to go to
exactly they didn't know what to say and
who to say what to because also michael
jackson told them things like
you can't tell anyone we'll both go to
prison if you if they find out
so this is why i wanted to say that what
happened to me as well because it's like
if a
big masculine blow can admit that that
then if you're watching this and you're
a young kid young lad and you feel
embarrassed like you shouldn't feel
embarrassed because
you didn't ask for that and i think as
mad as this is especially if you're a
straight lad
there's a part of you that thinks you'll
get the fun made of you
for being gay yeah now there's nothing
wrong with being gay but if you're not
gay and you're scared that people think
you're gay because this happened to you
people won't think you're gay you didn't
ask for that you weren't wanting dick
you weren't wanting anything no one's
saying everyone understands that
and actually that it's not your fault
it's also worth saying
those people who say that are are cut
they're also people who don't understand
the situation and it is it's also
partly because those people don't want
to understand it because that is such a
terrible thing
to happen and that's why people throwing
jokey words around like nuns
it's a bad bad thing because if you're a
victim
of a pedo you're you're gonna worry
about what everyone thinks of you
and then you hear all these jokes being
oh everyone's gonna make a joke about me
everyone's gonna make fun of me
[__] them you know you've gotta be able
to speak up you also i think that's
maybe that also differences you don't
necessarily write your story
and you don't tell the story in terms of
being a victim of that i think
some people nearly could have been
exactly and that's the point is actually
just because you have been the victim of
something terrible or someone has done
something terrible to you doesn't mean
you always have to cast yourself in that
light you're not always going to be
that identity that person but it you
have to do it's very hard not to feel
that way though yeah and i understand
that
and even though nothing happened to me
even recounting that moment in my head
i'm like
just almost becoming a victim yeah and i
was
like i was mistreated in that respect
but
it could have been way worse even
recounting that makes you feel a bit
like uncomfortable yeah yeah and a
little ashamed
a little so i can't even imagine how bad
it is for people who've had the really
bad things
so it's going to be hard but people like
this
if we hammer them when they come out and
speak
in a documentary like this one and and
shame them
all it's going to make is other victims
not want to say anything and and let's
be honest like
you know if these guys had massive flaws
in their story and
you know we'd be sitting there saying
this this this the amount of
identical things that they've shared in
this
detailed account of his sexual
preferences the things he did to them
the things he gave to them
you know we need to be applauding these
men
not having a go at them you know what i
mean
and i think the other side of it is
michael jackson
uh was in a very unique sort of a once
in a
maybe generation type situation where
there was clearly terrible traumatic
things that happened to him
clearly there were clearly he was in a
very unique situation in a world when we
were surrounded by people all the time
didn't know who you could be close with
didn't know who all these kind of things
he was constantly reinforced with this
identity which means that when we when
we're trying to look at him we don't
know what mental illness he had we don't
know
if even if you can call it mental
illness if it is basically just the way
his brain was wired
was changed because he'd been through so
much i think he had things wrong with
him but he was clearly thinking
logically
um in in some respects because he was
able to
cover his tracks incredibly well until
until he died i think that's what really
also freaked me out was when you're
watching the video of him sitting next
to the child when the child's talking
he's kind of laughing to punctuate the
child's speech
because it's almost like haha remember
don't [__] say anything huh
like we know what we've agreed there's a
shades of jamie savile about it where
it's like that guy was so public and
like uh ballsy about it in a way that it
made it hard to believe
he said well why would he then sit next
to a kid and have an interview and
say oh i love kids and all these kind of
things but he pr
wise he very much went on a bit of a
offense charlie absolutely
because right after the first uh big
thing
he did a lot of things with surrounded
by kids singing with kids
and then also he went and got married to
lisa murray presley
they had no kids well that's because
some people say it was chemically
castrated
personally there's a lot of people
saying that yeah they're
to me to my knowledge there is no proof
other than
his uh doctor and and the the guy who
was
clearly a whack job and other people
repeating the rumor
you know these young men were you know
were saying otherwise it seemed so
the point is he never had kids uh with
the women he was with and you know he
ended up having
um surrogates and whatever yeah exactly
and when he when
he was explained to one of the young
lads um in the
dark saying i'm gonna have to marry
someone now it's not gonna mean anything
but i just need to do it for pr
so that people think i like women yeah
and and to be honest the entire
time he was with lisa murray presley it
just looked like a sham
and slightly reliance again on another
big famous name covering
100 percent like macaulay culkin yeah
yeah people say oh well he didn't molest
mccauley cult and it's like well he
might have done he might not have done
mccolly colton says he didn't i take his
word for it
however five out of five lads who shared
his bed said he did
just because he didn't molest macaulay
culture doesn't mean he didn't also
do all these other things being the
clever man that michael jackson was
today it's amassed the hundreds of
millions
he is smart enough to think lisa marie
presley
good wife she's a big name big star
adjoining of the families that presley
family in the jackson family
and then also macaulay called if i have
him as a friend but i do nothing to him
when he speaks massive his opinion
macaulay [__] culkin isn't
harry potter he was a bigger star than
any child stars ever [__] lived
macaulay culkin he
is going to have a harder heavier
weightier opinion in a court of law
than anyone else you can bring in so if
he's speaking for you
you're good at that point you don't even
need the court of law because
if another child hears macaulay culkin
they go maybe i wasn't
yeah maybe i wasn't maybe i shouldn't go
up against this child star all those
kind of things and i think
and another thing that what zayn uh
sorry wade said when he went into um
court he said i i kind of like defending
him i like being the hero because
you get rewarded you know and and when
he come out and he seen michael
jackson's fans
he gave them the yeah give them the
jackson pose like team jackson
because to be associated with jackson
for his career is still good
and then yeah so there was benefits in
it for
weird to just do that you know which go
both ways yeah so it can't
it isn't just one side i can't think
that there's
i mean maybe people say money but
looking at the pain and the anguish in
his face and all the detail this isn't
i don't believe this is for money also a
lot of doors are going to close on you
after that so you might have the money
but there are going to be a lot of
your life will not be the same after
that so that's going to be tricky
there is the there is the other aspect
of people saying
why do this now michael jackson is gone
he's not
and i find it difficult when people say
he's not here to defend himself
because i think well there are still a
lot of people around who are still
making money from his estate are still
doing trouble
the people are still we've heard his
defense though we've heard him go
this is a big lie yeah it's ignorant
it's the same [__] he always said we've
heard him defend himself against this
many times
he never comes out and gives any
detailed explanations just as a big lie
when i'm watching a detailed account to
someone who's con
who is trembling as he holds on to the
jury that michael jackson
or when he's describing you know
what it was like to have michael
jackson's penis in his mouth yeah when
he's talking in that kind of detail
that's horrible i believe it i [__]
believe it the what struck me was
it's not about just about michael
jackson anymore and oprah said that it's
it's also about other people have been
abusing other abusers
it's also about people who enabled him
within his team within his camp to be
that abuser
and those people will have been turning
a blind eye consistently to michael
jackson doing things
his cleaner said she found little boys
underwear
she's seen him in the shower with um
one of the boys there now that and and
not only that but then go to vanity fair
website there are ten things ten damning
conclusions there are all sorts of
articles
out there which are just piling evidence
up if you want to keep denying it
or if anyone wants to keep denying it
that denial
is doing an injustice to the the
messages that people attach to michael
jackson
and you're being intellectually
dishonest and in my words you're just
bullshitting yourself
right saying the same thing but twice it
it's a very good documentary though it
made me
it makes you really question things and
i think we've still got a long way to go
in this
yeah i know there's going to be a lot of
hate as from michael jackson group on
here
and you know say what you want do what
you want um but it was a moving
documentary for me and i just felt like
we should talk about it we do
we've talked about some things we've
watched before but this was it deserved
it
he shouldn't be held up in the same way
anymore we can't we cannot hold no way
i mean i i used to love michael jackson
songs i'm not listening to him ever
again
that's it really that's a real shame
yeah well
this is one [__] fault there will be
other sides to it there are many music
producers out there
that's their career that's their work
their ministry i feel sorry for some
people like i don't know like maybe
quincy jones
right yeah people people who whose
greatest work
was uh you know michael jackson music
you know that was their
career-defining moment and now it's
tarnished you know those people but
there are a lot of people at the top who
don't want this story to come out
because i think they will be revealed
as terrible people and when it goes to
trial or
wherever it goes i'm sick to death of
people just claiming
big lie like give me something better
than that you [__] pricks yeah
you know one of the things i i remember
we're going all over the shop here
because it's a [__] emotional subject
there was always a different kid and
when and when wade talked about
how he'd been replaced the jealousy and
and how he felt yeah
yeah and but when they'd get to a
certain age you'd get a younger one
you get a younger one you get and he
clearly had a type and they're all very
handsome
looking young lads you know what i mean
it was clear like what you went for as
well and it's like people don't believe
conspiracy theories out there and
whatever
but how much evidence do we [__] need
like you know what i mean
yeah it's a joke at this point it's
quite sad as well
and there is an element of tragedy there
there will be a big sense of loss for a
lot of people like your feeling
with the music and with the imagery i
think the main thing is i just feel
sorry for the victims and the victims
families because
you know that mother i don't know if you
got that far in the dock but there was a
mother
of um wade's mother wasn't allowed
around the house
yeah because the wife was so furious
with her because it's like
as a mother herself how could you let
him how could you give him over to him
like that and not keep an eye on him and
and the other mother
she got a [__] house bought for her
off michael she said
when he died i was jumping for joy it's
like in the [__] house he bought you
you comply and prick i'm almost more
angry at the parents
really because they they put their kids
in
in danger and that is something that you
know a pedo is going to be a [__]
pedo
if you give them the chance they're
going to take the chance but your job as
a parent
is to keep them away from the period and
i'm the pedo is the worst in this
scenario obviously but the parent
should really hold a lot of [__]
blame in their heart i get what you're
saying
i also feel i can see the other side and
i felt i know
i ended up feeling very sorry for the
parents in this because some of those
people have done things that they were
naive to they didn't no
no i i agreed to a point yeah but
there's there's
there's there's something called
criminal negligence where
you're basically so dumb it's a crime
and and that is basically what these
parents do with what there's a lying way
michael's given them you know i just
want to have a night with him and all
this bollocks
there comes a point where you air should
be in the room with them
all times you know you shouldn't be
leaving your kid with a stranger
but the more they got phased out and the
more michael assumed the role of almost
guardian of some of these kids
it's like it's your kid just because you
he's got money and he's paying for you
[__]
you shouldn't just hand him over
disgrace there is something when i was
watching
i felt a little bit uncomfortable with
as well because i
i do remember thinking i'm i'm quite
kind
to kids i i've got three younger cousins
and i went to their birthday parties
and i would be the guy who was at the
birthday party like oh let's play a game
do this and do that
and i always remember thinking i really
want the parents to be around to make
sure that i'm
you know covered for these sorts of
things and it ruins it it's a different
world
there are many people it's because of
people like michael jackson
that men especially now need to feel a
bit
more am i doing the right thing even
though there's there's nothing but
goodness in your heart sharing a moment
of joy with a kid
giving them a present whatever you want
to do and
but you yeah michael jackson has changed
the world yeah
but not in the way that we originally he
said you want to change the world you
[__] did it you [__] the other side
of
the other side i'd be really interested
in and i always think is important
and you know this psychological side of
this i think we should explore with
michael jackson i don't mean us i mean
the quiet the criminal industry people
who work in that area should explore
that
how how have we constructed a society
where people
are able to do this the biggest guy with
the most attention was able to construct
it'll never happen again that's the only
[__] silver lining this can't happen
again we say that but not the same way
we say that but i think
if we fail to learn the lessons and we
just go michael jackson badge all these
people good yeah and not are you gonna
explore that
then other people will be able to do the
same thing because you cannot
you cannot you'll be damned by history
at that point and michael jackson has
[__] it
well um that was our take on the leaving
neverland documentary let us know in the
comments
what the [__] you thought obviously it's
an emotional thing
try and sort of uh yeah if people are
saying things in the comments i i
don't waste your time and worrying about
what that was what other people think
just
leave your comment about you what you
thought the uh the other side of that is
i think a huge part of this is gonna
open up a lot of pain for some people
watching the documentary so if you do
want to talk to anyone we'll put a link
in the description
as for people to go and talk to someone
just talk to someone and start the
conversation
because that will help if you've had um
something serious happen in your life
like that
thanks for watching guys we'll see you
later